miles i wanted to start with you on this
because i know you were encouraged to
make the script your own here so
what would you say was the new idea or
the change you made
that you found wound up being the key to
making this feel like it was your own
voice
it's a great question i think it was
probably um one of the first things we
talked about was the narration
who's the perspective of the narration
was coming from for me there was this
key of
figuring out that that she could have
the ability of telling this story
because of a shared loss and a shared
feeling that
given that she had experienced an
absence the same way that
her brother had experienced an absence
that in a way she was justified in
telling his
story even though he wasn't there i
think that to me
was one of the first things that that
arrived that would be so good i just
want to say that out loud before i move
on to the next question but she is
something else on this
margo i know for you that this was one
of the very first projects you took on
at lucky chap so is there anything about
your experience making
dreamland that has influenced the
project that you work on through the
company since
god you've got great questions it
honestly every project we take on board
it
it comes about in a different way and it
and it and it's for a different reason
and sometimes it's it begins with the
filmmaker sometimes it's a script
sometimes it's a it's a character
uh or a story or a point of view that we
want to put out there in the world
so it it honestly changes every time and
and i don't know if dreamland
has necessarily changed the way we think
it's just
it's just something we're incredibly
proud of and we just we're just so happy
that it's finally going to be out there
in the world and it is so different to
you know the other films that we've made
and um i
but but it really connects with people
funnily enough like three very
close people in my life have said out of
all the films they've seen me and this
is their favorite
and i was like wow that's really and
they know me really really well so
i don't know what it is about this one
but i don't know that was martin
scorsese
well different from your film other
films on your filmography and it's also
got a uniquely classic
feel that i don't think we get often
enough now so i have a feeling that's
going to strike a chord with a lot of
people
i wanted to ask the two of you about
working together as collaborators on set
margot
and finn what is something that the
other did on this set
as a scene partner that you really
appreciated and hope to find
in other actors that you work with in
the future i mean that's a hard question
because there's a lot of stuff
i mean i just would like to say first of
all that i learned so much from working
with margo
and and lucky chap and miles and um
a lot of what margot brought on those
days in terms of her focus and
and her knowledge of camera and and all
of those things
um it really kind of invited me to
seeing a different side of things
also as a producer and a brilliant one
at that i was um
i was lucky to kind of get an insight
into how that works which most producers
don't do so
it definitely pushed me to to want to do
more things in this industry and try
other avenues
but just utmost um professionalism and
and and made me feel so comfortable and
and when i made mistakes or i i didn't
get things right
there was no judgment and then that's
something that i'll always appreciate
i don't remember you making a single
mistake i would say finn is
literally the perfect scene partner
and he's also he has a i mean it's a
really tall order in this film he has to
kind of guide us through it i mean he he
really is the center of the film his
his kind of journey is is the emotional
stakes of the entire film
so he has to hold the screen when he's
on screen on his own he's got so many
different dynamics and relationships
that are at play here and then there's
also
this allison and eugene dynamic and for
me
it's like it's a dream come true when
you work with someone who
both pushes you but is always there for
you
and that's what i found acting with finn
i was always
challenged i was always take like you
know caught off guard in the best way in
the way that was always going to make me
better
in that i feel like we just we work
really well together we kind of like gel
really well maybe it's because we have
similar work
work methods or styles or whatever or
because miles creates that current kind
of environment on set but
whatever that combination of things were
you just to have someone there that
kind of has your back but also is going
to push you to be better
that's the dream all right miles i'm
coming back to you now i'm going to put
up a light spoiler warning for this one
just so you could talk about it freely
but
i'm like mildly obsessed with the shot
design for the shower scene and i was
just wondering is that something
that you kind of knew immediately when
you came to the script that it was going
to look that way or is that from
workshopping and conversations with your
dp
we we knew instantly that if the scene
was going to be in there
there was going to be that kind of scene
that there were a lot of things i wanted
to avoid with that kind of scene
um and and
immediately what made sense was to go
into really what what would
what it's doing is putting the the
timeline in real time right so all of a
sudden we have this kid who's been
fantasizing about how his life could go
or how this could happen or what this
person's introduction could be or
whatever
and then to actually be in that
experience
to completely slow it down make it
happen you know in
in one unbroken very still shot that
kind of places these two characters at
their most vulnerable
without hiding it in a cut and and
showing
um showing the experience in kind of the
most grounded way possible
uh since it isn't a fantasy it's what's
you know it's the part that he's that
he's kind of making this
this emotional leap and so is she and
it's it's a really it was an incredibly
difficult
scene to get right on the page and then
it was a very easy scene
it felt like the second i didn't have to
have anything to do with it
and they were sitting there acting it
and you know i remember the first take
it's in you know first it was like nine
minutes or something and
there's no cut there's no nothing it's
just the two of them there
and it was incredible to watch and it
was incredible also to have the support
of margo and finn to say like yeah
you're not
crazy don't get coverage this works
you know what i mean and like that as a
as a filmmaker that's sort of all you
can ask for is for the people to really
believe in you
it's so well composed i'm very impressed
before i get kicked out of here i did
want to ask you
a uh pirates question margo very quickly
because
i feel like your involvement and
christina's is exactly what i needed
to get me hyped for another one of those
movies so what are you two
striving to bring to that film that we
have yet to see in that franchise
uh a lot of girl power no i it's too
early to talk about it but i appreciate
that you're psyched on the combo i love
christina obviously
i'm not a producer on pirates so i'll
sit back and and
kind of wait for the process the way
you're allowed to do as an actor which
is nice
i don't have to stress about it this
just yet um
but uh no we're really really excited at
the prospect of kind of um
yeah adding adding obviously a very key
female element to that
to that world clearly i'm very much
looking forward to that
thank you guys so much for your time
today huge congratulations on this one
thank you so much